welcome to thick boy fight news let's
dive in at the official weigh-ins for
ufc london patty the batty pimlet made
weight scaling out at 156 pounds for the
past several months pimplet has received
harsh criticism for his eating habits
and weight gain between fights in a
video obtained by mma junkie after
stepping off the scale patty responded
to his weight critics in typical paddy
fashion
56
pull out
kids
moving to the main event on saturday
night tom aspinall vs curtis blades
aspinall is a -130 favorite to win the
fight speaking new yahoo sports blades
expressed that being an underdog is not
something new to him i definitely think
people underestimate my athleticism even
to this day i don't think a lot of
people appreciate how athletic you have
to be to get takedowns they don't get it
and i don't care if they don't get it if
they want to underestimate my speed
power that's to their detriment
when asked how he expects the fight to
go down saturday blade said fans
shouldn't expect it to go to decision if
you look at heavyweight history it's not
too often you see a fight going five
full rounds he's never been to the
fourth round i believe and he's a guy
who hunts for the finish and when you
have one guy hunting for a finish that
opens up the door for the other guy to
finish too so i don't know exactly how
the fight will play out but it probably
isn't going to go five rounds
the first press conference for ufc 280
was held friday in london featuring
charles oliveira sean o'malley and balal
muhammad the trio fielded questions from
media and fans while michael bisping
mediated in video obtained by espn mma
when asked about matching up with his
opponent pyotr yan sean o'malley didn't
hesitate to heat praise over yon calling
him one of the world's best
peter's up i would say peter's a black
belt in in fighting you know he's as
high level as it gets um you know
it's exciting for me to go out there and
fight someone who i believe could be you
know in the top five pound-for-pound
pound count for pound fighters uh he's
got a dominating win over al joe in his
first fight so
you know uh
he's not really lacking anywhere so
that's what's so exciting about this
fight o'malley stated that a win over
yon would 100 percent put him next in
line for a title fight the contender
series alum talked about what it would
mean to be the first from the series to
hold the belt
that would be awesome the contender
series was a great opportunity for me
and a great opportunity for a bunch of
people it would be awesome to be the
first one to get the belt
when asked by a fan if after a victory
over yon a title eliminator rematch with
cheeto vera would interest him o'malley
said
i think uh a title shot aft if if i get
through peter i believe i earned this
title shot um i think me versus
cheeto
for my first title defense sounds pretty
nice i'll i'll get that fight back
regardless i'm gonna be doing this sport
for the next 10 years
i'll get that one back one of these days
moving on to the main event of ufc 280
charles oliveira was asked whether or
not his opponent islam makachev deserves
to fight for the title the bronx
responded that islam is making the most
of the opportunity is granted to him
well the fact is that he is dropping in
on a wave that is khabib's so he's
making good use it's an opportunity if
you want peace okay the war is here to
stay
asked whether potentially beating
khabib's friend and disciple and luring
khabib out of retirement was extra
motivation for oliveira he responded
well this is a question you need to
address him he has retired deservedly my
focus is on fighting in october back to
brazil fighting again in january
bisping didn't let oliveira off the hook
and followed up about a potential fight
with khabib oliveira didn't shoot the
idea down responding well we need to
respect people's opinions decisions of
course i respect what he has done
throughout the years if he chooses to
fight me of course welterweight below
muhammad spoke about his upcoming bout
with sean brady during the press
conference the two 170 pounders are
known for their grappling skills but
bella feels like he not only has the
advantage on the ground but is overall
the more skilled fighter i think i'm a
better grappler than him i think i'm a
better fighter than i think i'm better
everywhere so it's just whatever i
choose i feel like my last couple fights
i've been showing a different side every
single fight so this fight i'm just
gonna show another different side of me
after the ufc 280 press conference and
the ceremonial weigh-ins for ufc london
wrapped up two of the loudest most
entertaining and most promising stars in
the organization ran into each other on
the grounds sean o'malley sporting a
paddy the baddie wig greeted pimlet and
offered praise over the weight cut and
asked how long his saturday bout against
jordan levitt will last
year what the [ __ ] did you lose
before signing off for the day we're
going to leave you with some picks from
the pros for ufc london blades vs
aspinall give us your picks for tomorrow
in the comments patty the baddie vs
jordan levitt jack hermansen vs chris
curtis and finally the main event curtis
blades versus tom aspinall
uh i think tom assembly's gonna be the
next champion i got tom asking i wanted
to fight sean
curtis
oh
come on guys
sean what are you playing at
charles tom aspinall or curtis blades
i don't have a preference now i do
believe that they are both super
fighters and let's see what's going to
happen gotta love that fence
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shop
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
you